a terrorist act that's how Russia's
foreign minister described an incident
in the belgaro region near the border
with Ukraine this debris Russia claims
is what's left of a military transport
plane it says was shot down by Ukraine
Wednesday morning Russia says all 74
passengers were killed including 65
Ukrainian prisoners of War du to be
exchanged
the Ukrainian leadership knew perfectly
well about the upcoming exchange they
were informed about how the prisoners
would be transported but the IL 76
aircraft was shot down says this state
Duma official and retire General video
from the village closest to the crash
site shows a plane falling from the sky
and an explosion Ukraine has not denied
shooting it down but in a statement says
there was no information of the need to
ensure the safety of the airspace
because of PS being transported as they
have been in the
past in his nightly address Vladimir
zalinski said it is necessary to
establish all clear facts and called for
an international
investigation this assistant professor
of politics and international relations
says Russia's president and information
Russia disseminates should be viewed
with a high degree of Suspicion he uses
misinformation uh in order to influence
public opinion in the west and in
Ukraine uh to try to get his
way it is a critical time for Ukraine as
attention and funding is waning while
Russian strikes continue Ukraine needs
to be able to stay in the war needs to
be able to get Western weapons and
ammunition to continue on in the fight
Russia's foreign minister Sergey lavaro
called for an emergency session of the
UN Security Council for Ukraine to
explain what happened that session will
be held Thursday Crystal ganing Global
News London